hello everyone hope they are good that
was quite a long time as I told you in
the previous video I was going to be
busy because my brother was flying here
to Georgia and I was spending time with
him and showing him around the country
so yes I've been pretty much busy but
now I'm back to work back to trading and
of course I'm gonna share these daily
updates with you guys so first of all
let's talk about this drop over here
okay in the last video we were talking
about the possibility of
lower prices okay remember that we were
saying that in this situation here
it's true that this could have been a
deviation okay but we were also saying
that it was so in qualif weakness okay
so if you have to favor any direction
you would have been to the downside okay
and we mentioned this Support over here
at 28 300 why because you can see how we
got tested as resistance twice before
okay and you saw a sell-off on another
sell-off so this was naturally going to
be a potential support what happened
price just ripped to the downside okay
and it went to the range lows okay this
one over here that was our next support
so you can see how the levels play out
of course here we were not saying to
open the positions here we were saying
that we would only open Longs here if we
saw a deviation get back Above This
resistance line okay that was gonna be
the support tested a support and that's
when you can loan that's what we were
saying okay
otherwise if you don't see the deviation
and press continues to go lower then the
range lows over here they were going to
be the next support and you can see how
I played out okay because yes we were in
a range and we were also in our range
here those are two ranges so we broke
out from a range Dash to four into the
previous range that's what it has
basically happened so what can we expect
now
well it depends on the time frame okay
and higher time frame
um it's not looking good because we are
below the weekly 50ma you can see
um so basically what I think is that if
we fall off from these range loads okay
so if price comes lower okay then here
we're gonna be targeting lower prices
where well you have a couple of levels
of Interest okay you have this liquidity
pool over here
you have this week over here
okay you have this week over here are
twenty thousand seven hundred eighty six
okay that's the 50 but again it can go
to the hundred percent
and that's nineteen thousand five
hundred as we always say we always
Target the 50 of the of the week because
it can come lower fill the 50 and then
you know bounce again but that's what
I'm basically looking at no so far as
who are holding above the range lows I'm
not going to be looking at this targets
bought if we fall off from here
okay that's when you are shorting to
this midweek okay and that's a 20 500
ish that's in the in the higher time
frame only if we lose
the range lows okay on this level over
here okay then you go to this week it's
as simple as that and it doesn't sound
that crazy okay because this drop from
here that would be uh let me check
that drop is at 17 drop okay 16 drop but
from here from 31 800 that we open the
short from here that's uh 19 okay so
that drop is even less than what has
happened there okay or pretty much the
same so it doesn't sound that crazy when
you see it like that okay so for any of
you
the thing that ah 20K I don't think
we're gonna go to 20K well remember
there are 31 000 there was not people
talking about 25k do you think that
you're crazy it's as simple as that
because it was a 20 drop but it happened
and yeah it can happen again another 20
drop to this week
right so that's what I'm looking for
as soon as we follow from here all right
that's the setup that I'm looking at in
the higher time frame for shorting and
of course
opportunity in my opinion also for
altcoins
um but let me go now into short term
because if we go into the four hours
time frame
they're gonna look they're gonna look
now at this projection that we drew on
the Bitcoin soon update okay we were
talking about the retest of the range
loss again uh you can see that it
happened pretty much there all right but
I wasn't expecting a bounce okay so
that's when I open my long here
okay I was aware that we had this week
over here and for the guys of the course
I always mentioned that if price comes
and fills the 50 percent of the
Candlestick of the week but doesn't
bounce immediately then you have a
chance that it's going to consolidate
just to come lower and continue feeling
that week so I was aware of that and
that's why around 20 25
428 I think it was so it was somewhere
like around here okay that's why you
open another long okay
uh why because I'm expecting price to
come into this region of the mid-range
around maybe not 27 000 but 26 900 could
be a quite big resistance why because if
we check the weekly time frame that's
where the 50ma is okay check the top
left corner it says Ama 50. twenty six
thousand nine hundred okay so that
someone is going to act as resistance
right so if any of you that in long and
you're targeting the mid-range I would
suggest to sacrifice 140 dollars in
price action and go for that resistance
and the 50 EMA in definitely time frame
okay that's what I'm doing
it's not Financial advisable I'm just
telling you what I'm doing all right so
that's so far what I'm looking at okay
I'm looking for Longs in this Zone I
think that this candle
here that it happened right before
yesterday's Asian session I like that
koala because it confirmed my theory
okay you go to the 50 you feel the 50
then you consolidate then and then
you're expecting another drop to fill
more percentage of this week it happens
then you get a bounce and now as long as
we hold above the range lows here okay
we're gonna see price going higher to
this zone is that clear
so that's what I'm looking for now when
can this happen well it's true that
today we have Nvidia earnings reports
but that's after the market closes okay
so where I'm gonna see Bitcoin really
moving until probably tomorrow right at
the start of the new job session okay
the end of the London session start of
the New York session okay because that's
when the U.S market is going to open and
it's going to react very aggressively to
what has happened the day before okay
with nvidia's earnings so
um if Nvidia earnings don't miss
and they are indeed good everyone is
expecting them to be good so if they are
not good then we should see some kind of
a bounce
okay and Bitcoin can is going to take
advantage of that and then that's when
you can see this prediction
playing out
all right but again that's what I think
um that's only my opinion I think that
the Media Earnings reports could be a
catalyst uh and if and if so then today
we might see a bit of boring price
action okay also if you look at the
chart here don't forget that here you
have a strong resistance okay in this
Zone
the literally since since Friday and
today it's Wednesday we've been all the
time below this resistance so as long as
you see Bitcoin pushing higher then you
want to see the retest of this
resistance support and that's when also
you can long if you haven't longed it
here because you think that there is no
most momentum which is true there is not
much momentum but also you have to think
that the lows when you see this kind of
behavior the loss of consolidation and
you start to see what's the downside
like this
that is telling you that the market
making is accumulating for what good
potentially happen next okay so if I had
to choose from here thinking that we are
at the range lows
um
so far we're holding above them okay you
had this week got filled uh pretty much
last night I think if I have to favor a
direction from here in the short term
and I'm talking for the next 48 hours
so a little between today and Friday
night then it should be to the upside
okay
maybe to do watch this Zone over here so
that's where my where my chart is
telling me right now we'll see if it
plays out or not again uh of course if
Nvidia misses the earnings reports and
they are bad
there is no doubt a Bitcoin is going to
go down and it's gonna break below this
zone no doubt about it so if you're
gonna play safe you can wait after the
Imperial Rings reports to see how how
they are and if they are good then you
can think about maybe opening Longs okay
otherwise
if you open along now and you don't have
a stop loss and in mediating reports are
bad
then I'm sorry
they're probably gonna go low okay but
so far what I think is that there is a
chance the mbdm reports maybe they are
not as good as everybody is anticipating
okay but I think that might be good
enough to hold above the range lows and
naturally that's when Bitcoin can go up
so that's pretty much everything that
I'm looking at okay uh something like
this projection uh of course your
confirmation will be once you break
Above This resistance and test your
support so that would be kind of like
here in this moment over here okay
that's when you can long but again the
market might be waiting until
nbdsn reports because at the end of the
day I think a media has a market cap of
1.13 trillions and the mark the crypto
Market
it's a 1.02 trillion so we could say
that in media just envidia has a bigger
Market Capital than the whole crypto
Market it's as simple as that so if
natural it is when I move the market
okay this area in reports so that's
pretty much everything guys stay safe
okay don't go with crazy leveraging I've
opened in lungs um if you want to save
then wait until the reports are out and
see how you play that okay and if you
have catch this long over here okay then
you can either play you the stop loss or
break even or below this week okay
somewhere like around here and see what
happens so that's pretty much what I'm
what I'm doing to be honest with you
let's see what happens from here I'll
post another video tomorrow I'm also
gonna work now with some altcoins I'm
gonna see their charts I want to see how
they're looking because the Bitcoin
dominance chart I know I know some
people are talking about this okay but
if we go into the daily time frame
what is happening here okay oh wait this
resistance
is getting tested a support
hmm
okay so I'm Gonna Leave You with that uh
and tomorrow I'm gonna post another
Bitcoin daily update because I'm
anticipating that there is going to be
some moves and I'm also going to talk
about their ring reports of Nvidia all
right but this week I'll give you my
word that I'm going to post
um a couple of videos about outcomes
okay probably maybe on the weekend so
that's pretty much everything guys thank
you so much for watching and I'll see
you soon